hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar identifying cellular diversity
through single-cell genomics i am
michelle ashton of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by Beckman
Coulter to learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.michigan.gov/mstep
resin tation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
best offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. Abbas
frisbee molecular neuroscientist
chuckerman mine brain behavior Institute
at Columbia University for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
Abbas you may now begin your
presentation Thank You Michelle
I'm honored for the opportunity to
present and thank you all for joining
the goal of the presentation that you
will see is to understand by way of
highlighting examples how single-cell
sequencing may be utilized to understand
the establishment development and
maintenance of cellular structures I'd
like to begin just by simply
highlighting the following example
imagine if you had a group or a clonal
population of cells on the left that are
all identical and over time these cells
differentiate into a heterogeneous
population of cells that you see on the
right this example is an embryo body and
these mouse embryonic stem cells are
transitioning into motor neurons but of
course this is just one example of where
a group of cells that are highly similar
can suddenly become very different from
one another and this has unique
importance when you think about a system
like cancer where you want to understand
what's happening in a tumor as it
progresses and how are cells within a
hypoxic Center different from those at
the margins of that tumor so clearly
what that example highlights is that
understanding individuality is of
paramount importance both from a basic
science perspective but also in
consideration of translational
importance so how do we gain access to
cellular diversity how do we understand
how one set of cells which are seemingly
identical to one another can become so
unique
in different well if we highlight the
following example if we take a complex
tissue type like the spinal cord within
the central nervous system and I'll have
more to say about that in a moment and
we were to isolate individual cells for
example by using flow cytometry or
alternatively density centrifugation
when you're looking for nuclei can we
generate cDNA from single cells sequence
and map against the transcriptome and
then analyze in a way where we can find
unique markers for each particular cell
type and an exciting direction that will
be the subject of possibly a different
webinar we could then multiplex in situ
sequence to be able to understand where
those cells are spatially distributed
within that complex tissue so we'd like
to be able to do is go from a complex
tissue and understand all of these
different cell types throughout
development and an adult and be able to
create atlases of these cell types and
when we want to do something like that
we really want to consider the layered
and stratified nature of gene regulation
when we consider gene regulation we
understand that genes have a particular
structure associated with their
regulation and that's dictated by
promoter sequences near the
transcription start site where the basal
transcriptional machinery is capable of
binding and that there exists enhancer
elements both proximal and distal which
bind transcription factors and through
action at a distance
we have stimulated transcription and
subsequent splicing
but we also have to consider that there
are other factors for example we know in
prokaryotes that there exists
transcriptional repressors we don't have
that in mammalian systems rather we have
other mechanisms at play and the example
here is if we consider chromatin
architecture and we understand that
closed chromatin is refractory to gene
expression whereas open regions of
chromatin enable activated gene
expression well you could either look at
the system by considering transcription
or you can think about chromatin
architecture when trying to understand
cellular diversity and what that really
speaks to is that there are multiple
experimental readouts of cellular
diversity I just told you about DNA
accessibility is one example but you
could also have long-range chromatin
interactions so for example someone can
do single cell hi-c experiments to be
able to understand cellular diversity
and of course when we look at activated
transcription we're looking at RNA
sequencing and then finally we could try
to understand something about protein
abundance in individual cells and try
and gain some sense of which cell is
which for the purposes of our
conversation today we'll focus on single
cell RNA sequencing but I do want you to
be aware that there exists workflows
that enable you to look at such systems
in a multi-modal fashion that is by
combining two or more of these readouts
with one another but let's get back to
the spinal cord everybody here can
relate to the following scenario there's
a flame there's an individual who is
burned by the flame and there are pain
receptors in the skin that then take
those sensory afferents and deliver them
to the spinal cord and up to the brain
which then sends motor commands out down
to the through the spinal cord and that
you have motor afferents or outputs
which are mediated by motor neurons that
innervate muscle ouch that hurts
your hand retracts and so what somebody
might want to be able to do me in
particular is trying to understand all
the different cell types that would
mediate our ability to respond for
example to experiencing pain and
subsequently being able to take action
but this is actually a pretty
complicated set of circumstances when we
look at the human spinal cord we know
that there are thirty-one segments along
the rostra caudal axis and that is from
cervical down to sacral and we
understand that cellular diversity is
largely a function of where you are
along that roster caudal axis whether
you are in the cervical thoracic lumbar
or sacral regions of the human spinal
cord furthermore we understand that in
the middle if we look at a cross-section
of the human spinal cord we see that
it's an incredibly complex structure
whereby there exists
sensory neurons that largely occupy
where afferent sensory signals come in
and that we have motor neurons down
towards the bottom at the ventral horn
which then would send motor output and
when we take a more granular look at the
spinal cord we see that there exists a
Sargasso Sea of cell types that are
patterned in this rostra caudal and
dorsal ventral manner now of course we
know that there exist neurons both
excitatory and inhibitory there exists
astrocytes which are the support cells
for these neurons microglia are the
immunological guardians of the central
nervous system
there exists oligodendrocytes which form
myelin sheaths that protect the axon
there are also ependymal cells which
provide a critical barrier between the
cerebral spinal fluid and the remainder
of the central nervous system now when
we think about such a complex situation
and trying to understand how you can
develop and maintain such a complex
structure we want to try to reduce the
system down and
something that we can understand one
cell at a time and so
to discuss with you is the possibility
of understanding neurogenic commitment
of motor neurons with single-cell
resolution now of course all cellular
diversity begins at fertilization
whereby you have an egg that upon that
fertilization subsequently divides into
a blast Amir as you'll see on your right
and then through subsequent development
you get a beautiful central nervous
system as you'll see in this embryo that
is formed and in green is the spinal
cord labeled in this clarified embryo
and one thing that we can do with these
blastocysts is we can isolate mouse
embryonic stem cells and we can actually
differentiate these mouse embryonic stem
cells into a wealth of different
neuronal cell types and so what we'll
discuss in a moment is the directed
differentiation of mouse embryonic stem
cells into motor neurons and that
provides a platform to be able in vitro
to understand how motor neurons arise
from a clonal population of cells so
let's go back to the example that we
started out with at the beginning of
this presentation imagine that I have a
collection of mouse embryonic stem cells
and that I'm looking at them over time
over a six-day differentiation protocol
whereby I induce these mouse embryonic
stem cells twice on day two with
retinoic acid and sonic hedgehog and on
day four with retinoic acid and sonic
hedgehog now these mouse embryonic stem
cells are actually special because they
contain a trans gene for motor neurons
that is hb9 driving the expression of
egfp that means that all of the green
cells that you see on day six are in
fact motor neurons and so the question
is how do these cells actually transform
from embryonic stem cells into the
diverse diverse population that you see
on day six and in fact this is of
critical importance because when we're
trying to understand the biology of
motor neurons we can actually dissociate
these green cells sort them using flow
cytometry and be able to culture them
and subsequently study disease states so
course hopefully this motivates to you
why it's important that we understand
how this diversity comes about over time
but there are some considerations that
we need to really take into account when
we're trying to understand a population
of differentiating cells imagine the
following thought experiment I begin
with a clonal population of stem cells
at time point one and they're all highly
similar to one another and when I look
at the middle boxes in this case you see
all of these cells if I were to profile
their transcriptome because the cells
are all similar to one another if I took
all of the cells and profiled them in
bulk or taking the ensemble average that
ensemble average would reflect what's
happening in this dynamic system but if
I look at time point two you would see
in the differentiation trajectory that
some of the cells are a little bit
behind and show some stem cell
characteristic but at a branch point
they start looking more like
type 1 and another population is
differentiating towards cell type 2 now
if I took the ensemble average of that
transcriptome over that entire
population it would Balai what's
actually happening on the right with
single cell resolution and of course
when we look at timepoint 3 we now have
fully differentiated cell type 1 and
cell type 2 and of course doing bulk RNA
sequencing would certainly not give you
any felt sense of what's actually
happening but now if we did single cell
RNA sequencing we may be able if we're
clever enough to be able to contend with
the asynchrony branched nature of
differentiating processes so let's think
about an experimental design remember I
told you that we have day 2 through day
6 of our differentiation ongoing and if
we were to take these individual embroid
bodies and we were to dissociate them
and sort into individual wells of say a
96-well plate or it could have been a
384-well plate we can utilize cell seek
which is a published protocol but we've
optimized using liquid handling systems
to be able to reverse transcribed with
an inline cell specific barcode in each
well we can pool the cDNA resulting from
the reverse transcription and in vitro
transcribe and generate a cDNA library
for sequencing and we did that over
2,000 743 single cells yielding 7,000
genes detected per cell but what do you
do when you actually have data like this
it's actually not exactly trivial how do
you contend with trying to analyze and
interpret results that may come through
from an experiment like this
and the idea that I had was thinking
about considerations of shape now I had
read a publication that gave some
information about topological data
analysis as a method to be able to
understand how shape might help you gain
access to biology so let's take a quick
break from single-cell sequencing and
think about topology
apology is all about understanding
invariance shape associated with any
three-dimensional structure so by way of
example there are mathematicians that
sit and think very carefully about a
double toroid system like we're looking
at on the left and what they seek to be
able to do is create reduced
representations that is to say a
skeleton and that skeleton actually
tells you something about that shape so
when we look to the right this is known
as a reap graph and that tells you that
Gus you know I have actually two
invariant holes if I went from the top
to the bottom of that particular
structure and that tells you something
about shape
but of course the real world is not
continuous structures in fact our
measurements are discreet and so we
positioned ourselves to be able to
utilize topological data analysis and in
topological data analysis what you're
doing is you're taking a collection of
data points as you would see on the
right and inferring that they actually
are a circle as you see on the left and
of course that gets increasingly
difficult as your data becomes more
complex even in the bottom case where
you're looking at two circles so how do
we actually do topological data analysis
when we're thinking about high
dimensional single-cell data so when you
generate single-cell RNA sequencing data
one might think that each data point
could potentially be a 24 by one vector
and so that constitutes a very high
dimensional data set when you're
considering a large number of individual
cells and those data reside in a high
dimensional plane and so on the left we
call this point cloud data and as with
any kind of high dimensional data we
dimensionally reduce as represented by
f1 now that f1 could be principal
component analysis it could be T
stochastic neighbor embedding and you
dimensionally reduce your data into a
lower dimension embedding as you see
along this real line as I show you right
in the middle of the slide and what we
can do is we can create patches along
our dimensionally reduce data and with
those patches we can then refer back to
the high dimensional data that you see
on the left and we ask how are those
cells actually related relative to one
another
in the high dimensional plane
and once we've done that we can actually
then create nodes so for example in
green we see a set of cells that have a
highly shared transcriptional profile
and we can group those cells into a node
and we see in red there are two other
nodes of cells that actually have highly
shared transcriptional profiles but you
notice that between the group of cells
in red and the group of cells in green
that there exist cells that have shared
transcriptional profiles and those
actually fall into edges of these graphs
and so what this allows us to
potentially do is to be able to capture
continuous structure existing within
single cell data so let's just review
this is the point of the webinar and
trust me I've seen this talk before
where everybody should just kind of sit
up put your phone down if you're surfing
on the internet maybe stop for just a
moment a node represents a microstate a
group of cells that have a similar
transcriptional profile an edge between
two nodes represents a shared group of
cells so let's make sure we're all on
the same page because we'll begin
thinking about topological
representations of single cell data
quite extensively moving forward so what
we did was we took our data from our
single cell differentiation and we then
created a topological representation and
what we see and it's actually quite
striking is topological data analysis
perfectly ordered these differentiating
cells on the left you see mouse
embryonic stem cells from day to rapidly
transitioning into neural precursors
which you see in a lighter blue and then
multiple paths that bring you to
progenitors and then subsequently motor
neurons which are colored in red and of
course that occurs on day six now of
course this is an experimentalist you
want to be able to look at your data and
sanity check and say well is this
consistent with biological understanding
that is known about this system and so
what we can do is simply highlight and
ask if I have known markers for each of
these given cellular states where do
they reside within this topological
representation for example if I look at
och3 for which is a Yamanaka factor it
seems to be highly represented in mouse
embryonic stem cells and dying down as
we move towards neural precursors and
you can see that in light pink all of
two labels progenitor cells that give
rise to motor neurons and Voxx
is an acetylcholine transferase that
actually labels motor neuron
so everything seems to jive with
expectation and that's good
however what we want to be able to do is
build out a statistical method to be
able to analyze and interpret these data
without using any kind of bias that is
to say without anchoring ourselves in
knowns about the system can we actually
use this as a platform for discovery so
we set out to create that statistical
framework by first trying to infer a
timescale for progression usually in
sequencing experiments we want to think
about pseudo time that is creating
transformation that instead of thinking
about experimental time we're now
parameterizing in context of
transcriptional State and so here we did
that by defining a root node that is a
node that maximizes the correlation
between graph distance and chronological
sampling time and in doing so we're
actually able to transform ourselves
into pseudo time
but in addition to that what we also
want to do is we want to get some sense
of confidence about where genes are
expressed and localized along these
types of graphical representations that
is to say that I want some sense of a
p-value that I have some confidence in
my results and so what we then define is
gene connectivity and that quantifies if
nearby cells in the graph express the
same gene transcript more than random so
on the left you see Vox which we would
expect to see actually highly localized
in motor neurons and of course it has an
extraordinarily low p-value whereas if
we take a gene that is expressed
scattered throughout the graph we then
see that its p-value is subsequently
quite high
but we also want to know where we are
along that graph and so what we did was
we utilized two metrics centroid and
dispersion characteristics that tell us
where our transcripts actually appearing
along these graphs and how do they
distribute themselves across that and
when we actually take the centroid and
dispersion relationships in these graphs
what we're able to do is in an
unsupervised way be able to identify
cellular states that is to say sets of
transcripts that are uniquely expressed
along these topological representations
now biologically why is this important
and what can we potentially learn when
we take centroid and dispersion
relationships what we're capable of
doing is in an unsupervised way being
able to identify cellular states
associated with this dynamically
differentiating system and that's
important biologically because we know
that their exists coordinated
transcriptional regulation associated
with cellular differentiation and
development and this allows us to see as
you can see on the Left we can find
coordinated gene expression that occurs
between pluripotent cells neural
precursors progenitors and neurons and
as you can see on the left you can
actually see waves of transcription
associated with neural development and
in fact what this allows us to do in an
unsupervised way is be able to identify
new markers associated with cellular
development so for example we find P cam
1
as a unique marker of mouse embryonic
stem cells and we can actually use amino
histah chemistry to be able to validate
these results so we see on our
topological representation that we can
call out peak m1 is a novel marker of
mouse embryonic stem cells and in fact
we can now stain embroid bodies against
peak m1 och3 for and on the very right
looking for HB 9 GFP or MN x1 is another
name for it GFP expression and what we
can see is a perfect co-localization
between peak m1 and awk 3 4 in these
mouse embryonic stem cells however when
we look at day 5 what we're able to see
is that in addition to all of 2 we can
discover that the endothelin receptor B
also uniquely labels our progenitor
population and in fact our
immunohistochemistry in an individual
embroid body shows perfect
co-localization interestingly we also
find that SLC 10 a4 which is a bile acid
transporter is a novel marker for motor
neurons now this is the kind of data
that you find in single-cell sequencing
especially when you're doing an
unsupervised analysis why would a bio
transporter be appearing in motor neuron
population and would that be consistent
with what you would find in vivo and
when we look in an embryonic stage
animal looking at SLC 10a for this bile
acid transporter we find absolute
congruence between HB 9 GFP that's the
marker for motor neurons and the
expression of this bile acid transporter
and you can see the motor neuron pool
and you can see the two limb innervating
axons coming out and they're perfectly
stained with an antibody against SLC 10
a4
moreover what this type of analysis
allows us to do is to be able to
discover expanded transcriptional
repertoire associated in a
functionalized manner that is by looking
at gene ontology we can now look at
regulators that are now associated with
the transition from potent cells to
neural precursors motor neuron
progenitors and neurons now you can see
why this of course is of paramount
importance and why this could actually
lend to a generalized workflow that is
of sufficient power and generality that
can be applied to any differentiating
population and I argue that because it
gives you the opportunity to be able to
identify key transcriptional events and
pivotal regulators associated with any
type of cellular transformation and of
course we've applied this workflow to
other published data sets and what that
has allowed us to do is even identify
hidden populations of single cells
associated with a differentiating
population here we're looking at
pre-implantation embryos and we can
already begin to determine
subpopulations of the troppo ectoderm
that were not previously understood but
go back to perhaps the more complicated
set of circumstances what if we wanted
to be able to try to look within the
human spinal cord and not just focus on
motor neurons but try to understand the
repertoire of all cell types that exist
within this complex tissue
well we initiated our work in trying to
build an atlas of the human spinal cord
by utilizing split seek it's a mechanism
of combinatorial indexing developed by
the Selig lab at the University of
Washington and in split seek what you're
doing is first reverse transcribing with
the first barcode but now you don't have
individual cells in each well of a plate
but a collection of cells and each of
that both collections of cells receives
a first round barcode you then pool
those cells redistribute them to a new
plate and you'll I get a second barcode
onto your cDNA you then pool and split
again and ligate the third barcode
you can then redistribute these cells
you can lie some and PCR with the fourth
barcode
it's a probabilistic bar coding scheme
that allows each cell to
probabilistically receive a different
first second third and fourth round
barcode
details are well worked out as to how
this occurs in a molecular scale you
begin with a round 1 bar coded primer
and then of course as I mentioned before
then at the 5 prime end begin ligating
second round barcodes block then apply a
third round barcode and a fourth round
barcode at the very end of this workflow
but of course one can imagine sure you
could do this by hand but that could be
somewhat difficult but we've managed to
be able to get this to work at a pretty
high level by automating using liquid
handling and so here you take stock
plates of nuclei and distribute them
along your plate and then reverse
transcribe and then begin pooling and
splitting in an automated way for each
bar coded round and what we're able to
do and this is an example over a large
number tens of thousands of single cells
in fact nuclei isolated from the human
spinal cord specifically the lumbar
region we are able to identify ensembles
of astrocytes neurons oligodendrocytes
microglia so on and so forth along
topological representations and so
hopefully what this motivates for
everyone participating in this
conversation is that topological data
analysis provides a meaningful path to
characterize continuous transcriptional
trajectories and single-cell
developmental studies as well in Atlas
studies and certainly integrated
workflows where you can combine flow
cytometry and liquid handling really
enables unfettered access to cellular
identity and the construction of cell
atlases of complex human tissue
finally I'd like to acknowledge the team
that I work with to be able to
accomplish my work and of course the
generous support of viewers like you
thank you
Thank You Abbas for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of the presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button Abbas will answer as many
questions as time permits okay let's get
started
our first question is you haven't
discussed droplet based approaches is
that a method you disfavor certainly not
I mean we also utilize droplet based
approaches in lab however many of the
things that I've discussed with you here
are things that are not particularly
off-the-shelf there are things that
allow us to tweak and optimize and
certainly that can be done in a droplet
based format however we find that we get
a little bit more flexibility when we're
using flow and liquid handling
you you've made a pretty convincing
argument that flow cytometry can offer
value in single self studies is there a
reason to believe that flow cytometry
can alter ourselves transcriptome and
skew your results when you build your
atlas yeah that's actually a really good
point Michelle thank you for asking here
in our atlas studies we're actually
isolating individual nuclei so these
nuclei are isolated from post-mortem
human tissue and there we don't see any
kind of changes of course because the
nuclei are no longer actively
transcribing however there are ways with
flow so let's say for example someone
wanted to study something in a mouse
where they had fresh tissue from a human
what you'd want to be able to do is
dissociate for individual cells but
there are treatments like utilizing
actinomycin that can actually block
active transcription and so there are
many ways to be able to contend with the
possibility that flow may skew results
in our experience if you are doing this
just right usually everything will work
out where you'll actually get something
close to a transcriptional state that is
comparable to what's resident within
tissue
thank you some of the analysis you've
shown some somewhat advanced are their
analytical strategies that can help
newcomers to the field interpret their
data yeah so that's actually a really
good question and usually that tends to
be the barrier to doing any kind of
single cell genomic work I will say that
there are plenty of tools that are
available Syrah is one example you have
scan Pi which is a Python based
implementation of single-cell analysis
tools that are quite accessible and so
you know one of the wonderful things
about single-cell sequencing is that it
really has rapidly evolved and it's
through the good work of computational
biologists that there are tools like
that that enable people right away to be
able to analyze and interpret their data
that having been said I always recommend
that a computational biologist be
associated with kind of a first pass of
trying this just to make sure that
you're doing everything correctly but
there absolutely are plenty of tools
available in fact the analytical
approach that I mentioned here with Papa
logical data analysis we have available
on github
it's called SCT da and we have an entire
software suite that enables in a very
open source way anyone to be able to
build these kinds of topological
representations and statistically
analyzed along these graphical
representations so yes there's
absolutely tools out there and they're
quite accessible
again Thank You Abbas for your time
today do you have any final comments for
our audience before we go yeah I think
that again although I focused on
neuronal systems or systems within the
central nervous system I really think
that it's important to recognize the
power and generality associated with
single-cell genomics and the biological
insights that can be afforded by doing
these types of experiments and so if you
are hesitant in any way to give these
things a shot consider really the
massive benefit of looking at cellular
systems one cell at a time
thank you I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
questions any questions we did not have
time for today will be addressed the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor Beckman Coulter for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event until next time goodbye